en esta ocasión les voy a hablar de algo
llamado eutrofización esta palabra viene
del griego que etimológicamente
significa bien nutrido eu
y hace referencia a bien a bueno
mientras que trozos trofeos hace
referencia a nutrición así que tal vez
lo primero que pienses al ver esta
palabra es que es algo bueno pero como
verás en el transcurso del vídeo
este término habla de sobre nutrición
pero en este caso de una sobre nutrición
al punto que causa cosas desagradables a
nuestra biosfera así que la idea general
consiste en hablar de cosas como el
nitrógeno y en especial el fósforo que
es el factor que facilita la tasa de
rapidez con la que crecen las plantas ya
hablamos acerca del nitrógeno en algunos
vídeos sobre el ciclo del fósforo
recuerdas y nosotros los seres humanos
agregamos un montón de nitrógeno y
también en especial fósforo a las
plantas para que crezcan mejor porque ya
saben necesitamos a las plantas para
vivir para obtener comida y entonces lo
que está pasando es lo siguiente imagina
que por aquí no tenemos algún tipo de
tierra
voy a poner aquí algún tipo de tierra
algo más o menos así imagínate qué es
una granja y en la granja aquí tenemos
un cierto cultivo déjame poner a este
cultivo y bueno aquí tenemos a unas
ciertas plantas así que las voy a poner
con este color tenemos un montón de
plantas así que las voy a poner este es
mi cultivo y bueno a este cultivo lo que
vamos a hacer es ahora agregarle
fertilizante entonces aquí tengo mi
cultivo quiero que crezca lo más que se
pueda y entonces le vamos a agregar
fertilizante entonces déjame escribirlo
a esto le agregamos fertilizante y bueno
tal vez este fertilizante tenga
nitrógeno y fósforo en forma de fosfatos
entonces le añadimos fertilizante y el
mayor culpable de lo que tiene el
fertilizante es justo el fosfato
así que el fósforo por una parte me va a
ayudar a que crezcan un poco más las
plantas para crecer un poco más y más
rápido mis plantas ok pero por otra
parte o dicho otra manera un efecto
secundario de este fosfato es que el
agua para el cultivo ya sea que provenga
de la lluvia o del riego el agua cuando
fluyen a través de los cultivos fluyen a
través de estos cultivos y va bajando
hasta llegar no sé a un arroyo a un río
o algún lago va a llevar un exceso de
fertilizante así que supongamos que este
es un lago ok y ahora como el agua viene
llena de fertilizante entonces este lago
va a tener un montón también de este
fertilizante y en particular de estos
fosfatos así que tenemos un montón de
fosfatos en este lago y ahora sabemos
que aunque los fosfatos ayudan a que
crezcan las plantas esto también va a
ayudar a que crece
organismos fotosintéticos como las algas
es decir el lago por sí mismo ya tiene
algas pero ahora si llenas el lago de
fosfatos las algas se van a volver locas
y entonces van a crecer por toda la
superficie del lago y es justo aquí
cuando me refiero que el alga va a estar
sobrealimentado y esto porque tendríamos
más fosfatos de los que naturalmente
tendríamos sin fertilizantes y bueno no
solamente los fertilizantes o como
también los detergentes
hay varios detergentes que tienen
fosfatos de sodio que una vez más causan
eutrofización muy bien y ahora
seguramente te vas a preguntar qué tiene
de malo que tengamos aquí a esta
cantidad enormes de algas vas a decir
bueno tal vez el agua se ve un poco más
verde o bueno es un poco menos clara un
poco menos translúcida pero bueno aquí
tenemos un montón de organismos viviendo
que puede estar mal pero el problema
viene
todas estas algas mueren porque cuando
todas estas algas mueren empiezan a
sumergirse van a empezar a sumergirse
adentro de este lago ok
sus cadáveres van a caer y luego lo que
pasa es lo siguiente las bacterias que
están en el lago comen estas algas estas
algas muertas pero si las bacterias
empiezan a consumir un montón de algas
bueno empieza a ver un montón de
bacterias en este lago y estas bacterias
también consumen oxígeno y ya hemos
hablado de la importancia del oxígeno en
la respiración
entonces las bacterias van a consumir
todo el oxígeno del lago y ahora bien
cuando pensamos en animales que habitan
el lago o el océano déjame poner por
aquí la superficie de este lago y voy a
poner por aquí a algún animal no sé se
me ocurre un pez voy a dibujar por aquí
un pez que esté bien feliz en este lago
aquí está mi peso y está bien feliz en
este lago bueno
este pez necesita oxígeno de la misma
manera que nosotros para poder vivir y
los peces no obtienen el oxígeno cuando
las olas rompen o cuando hay una cascada
y entonces entra el oxígeno al agua y es
justo así que estos animales marinos
pueden vivir pueden respirar ahora - y
tenemos por aquí a nuestras bacterias y
todas estas bacterias están consumiendo
el oxígeno del agua para poder
descomponer a toda la cantidad de algas
que cayeron al morir y recuerdan toda
esta alga muerta no se produjo por los
fosfatos entonces lo único que va a
pasar es que estos animales marinos ya
no van a poder vivir aquí se van a morir
y la ironía aquí es que por querer
fertilizar este cultivo para que crezcan
más rápido entonces los fosfatos hacen
la eutrofización lo cual está haciendo
que crezcan más un organismo que otro y
en este caso eso nos lleva a que se
consuma el oxígeno
que ayuda a otros organismos a crecer y
esto es lo que generamos
es lo que llamamos una zona muerta así
que este pez va a morir y aquí se va a
generar una zona muerta déjame
escribirlo
y esto porque no tenemos el suficiente
oxígeno y estas zonas muertas son un
problema serio aquí hay algunas
fotografías
en esta primera tenemos una zona muerta
por eutrofización y si muevo la pantalla
por aquí puedes ver otra y probablemente
has visto algo así sobre todo en lugares
donde desemboca el drenaje de aguas
residuales o algo así y realmente no se
ve así porque tenemos un exceso de
nutrientes que hacen que estas algas
eclosionen y se salga de control así que
cuando mueren estas algas las bacterias
las consumen junto con eso consumen el
oxígeno y al final nada más puede vivir
ahí y esto está pasando también a una
escala macroscópica y ahora hablan por
acá tengo otra ilustración donde vas a
poder ver todas las zonas en el mundo
que tienen austro fijación y puedes ver
que en general se encuentran en las
zonas donde hay más industrias en las
zonas donde hay una mayor cantidad de
agricultura y sobre todo una mayor
cantidad de industrias
agrícola donde obviamente usan más
fertilizantes y esto hace que además
desde las ciudades se manden todos estos
fosfatos que causan eutrofización y si
ahora nos fijamos por aquí y podemos ver
que este es el mar caspio y le hacemos
un acercamiento lo puedes ver justo aquí
esta es una imagen que ha sido tomada
por un satélite y en ella puedes ver que
hay austro fijación justo aquí toda esta
zona donde tenemos un color más verde en
esta zona y esta zona de acá tiene
eutrofización observa que el agua se ve
de un color distinto y bueno este es un
problema ecológico muy grave en el cual
tenemos que pensar en un nivel los
fosfatos y los fertilizantes y los
nitratos se ven como algo bueno algo que
nos ayuda con nuestros cultivos pero hay
que tener mucho cuidado en donde
realmente van a terminar